I feel for her he's in a mess this is  what happens when you marry a woman who  is far smarter than you before he met  Megan he used to hang out with blows  called Jasper roots and Montague  drinking pimps and deciding what Nazi  outfit to wear on a night out now he's  been forced to answer questions like how  can we dismantle a patriarchal  heteronormative Colonial system that is  oppressive to people of color and  infused with white supremacy Harry's not  going to be able to answer that the  blows got two a levels and one of them's  an enr he's called the intellectual  ability of the toenail and so what you  like about a toenails but at least  they've got the capacity for growth